foreign
let's go to Sherry in Salt Lake City
what's up Sherry
how's it going Dr John we are partying
what are you doing
good for you and by the way we
couldn't be further from partying right
now like I'm wearing a button-up shirt
like a [ __ ] it's fine it's good so
what's up
so
um it's so nice meeting you it's so nice
talking with you but
um uh I wish it was underneath better
circumstances
um what happened
well my question for you is is
how do you forgive yourself and move on
from the guilt and shame of past
mistakes
hmm that's a great question
I'm not great at this personally I can
give you all the academic answers I'm
not very good at it
um so the natural question I probably
wouldn't ask you this in a counseling
session in the way I'm going to ask it
now but it just makes for a better radio
Okay
um what'd you do
that were back to back
um one I'm actually currently with the
third one
um and my husband and I at the time were
just not doing well we we weren't
emotionally connected
um I had a ton on my plate in fact
looking back I I I'm like wow were we
ever emotionally connected
um at the time I was working full two
full-time jobs he was working full-time
as well
um I was homeschooling our special needs
kids
um I was maintaining a house that was
you know cooking cleaning laundry
um you know just budgeting if if the car
broke down that was on me to go and get
it fixed you know he would take the good
car to work I would have to somehow
figure out how to get the the bad car to
to the shop you know um I was actively
volunteering in the community I was you
know volunteering at my church
um and unfortunately we had also moved
to to a new area where I didn't have any
friends and
um you know we would we would talk about
things and I would I would say Hey you
know I really need some help
um and things would get better for maybe
a week and then they'd go right back to
maybe him providing about minimum effort
in in all these different areas
and it just warned me you know and I'd
have to say that I got in a pretty good
cycle of guilt and shame of not being
able to be successful you know as much
as I'd like to be in in these different
areas you know and
I
I don't like the way that things ended
um but they did end we we did end up in
divorce and I feel tremendous guilt of
of of breaking essentially and I know
these aren't you know to me these are
not excuses these are this is just
context of sort of what happened and
you know and and
even though I know that we were heading
for disaster that communication was just
non-existent basically uh we weren't
hearing each other we weren't
we weren't supporting one another the
way that we should have
I just hate the way things ended between
us and what I'm finding is is that it's
it's blocking me from being able to give
a hundred percent in my current
relationship
you haven't dealt with the core issue
after all this time you still haven't
dealt with it
do you want to know what it is
do tell me
um
well there's two two big glaring things
and if you go watch this on on YouTube
when it comes out you'll see I took a
bunch of notes while you were talking
um
two big glaring things here number one
you are trying to make me okay
but you keep speaking in terms of what
we were doing
and until me takes ownership of what me
did
there's never going to be congruence
does that make sense
and so all of your discussion of what
happened
was like you said it was a good context
but it was never
and then I went and did this and then I
went and did this not saying that I I
hundred percent know how you got there
right
but part of forgiving yourself is owning
and acknowledging reality and I don't
think you've done that maybe or maybe
you have and it's so painful because
you've got to deal with you
um that It's just tough to go there and
that leads me to number two which is the
overarching underneath and this is the
big entire neon sign is that cool
mm-hmm I don't think it's had anything
to do with your husband had anything to
do with your special needs kid
you didn't like who you were becoming
you didn't like who you had become
the first time you met somebody new
what how about this walk me through how
you met that person
um I I met them through work okay and
what does that mean so you just like
somebody you saw in the hallway and you
kind of laughed and it's kind of funny
uh just striking up conversations
um I was remote so you know striking up
conversations and you know the
conversations were very light
um I've had a lot of guy friends
throughout my life
um and so I didn't think anything of it
you know
and then I feel like it sort of snuck up
on me to tell you the truth
absolutely I don't think I don't think
for a second you set out to find a
replacement so take me take me from
light it's funny you think of a funny
joke or you send a funny emoji and he
writes back like that like lol like in
capital letters like it actually made
him laugh in real life and that felt a
little bit good and then like he
answered something in a zoom chat you're
like that guy's smart like walk me
through exactly how you ended up where
you were
um to the point that y'all met in person
the first time
honesty I think you know exactly
someone found me smart someone found me
funny
um someone wasn't demanding something or
expecting me to go above and beyond
what I had in me
and it was
refreshing to have someone
to uh
to sort of relax with
and what allowed you to relax
um because by the way this is all
happening on chat so most of this is
happening inside your head most of this
is a fantasy until y'all met up
yeah right like you were creating this
world I'll just cut to it because we can
do this for a long time
you're finally seen
through a filter of your own fantasy
and what's one what's if I distill it
all down what is one thing you felt
after all of this
you're dealing with special needs kid
who you love but God it's so hard you
love your husband but I just sit on the
couch again and there's laundry baskets
everywhere and he's like oh by the way
the car needs oil change
what did what did you feel
um
happiness
what's the word underneath that spark is
perfect that's really close
alive
again
and so how did y'all meet up
work conference just had to had ended up
having to go to a work conference
um and you know we we planned it
beforehand okay
and how'd you feel the next day
terrible
numb and almost like I I was
observing somebody else's life there you
go yeah because the fantasy filter went
away and suddenly it's
almost disassociative right
yeah because I'm Sherry I'm not a person
who cheats I'm a mom I'm a I'm a wife
I'm a worker I'm not somebody who cheats
yep
and now suddenly I found myself here
I'm the person that I judged and hated
there you go
was this person married too
I don't think so
okay
and what led to number two
uh first one stopped contacting the the
contact just went way down like you said
I think the fantasy just went away
and my ego was hurt
okay
and basically reached out to
the next person who would give me
attention okay
but you realize the person was a proxy
for the feeling of of being alive
yeah and so absolutely globally speaking
the
the challenge in any sort of romantic
relationship is
how do I how do how do how am I alive in
this relationship and how do we help
keep each other alive and that sounds
codependent and that's not what I mean
what I mean is how do we keep this fire
moving and not like it's it's fire not
like that but
how do I stay alive in this thing
and it's almost always through letting
your needs be heard and having strong
boundaries and having another partner
that's going to play along and you
didn't have that
and now you're in a situation was the
person you're with now were they with
somebody else
um they were at one point with somebody
else okay
so
the reason that relationships on the
back of Affairs are a mess is at the
core both of you know what the other
person's capable of
foreign
and it's very hard to put both feet on
the ground when you know
right
and so it takes and and the worst part
is is trusting myself yeah that's what
you say now I've seen yes now I've seen
what I'm capable of and it's like I
didn't even it's it's like jumping out
of an airplane you know it's like I'll
never do that and then all of a sudden
you do and you're like well I can now I
can now I know I can and it's it's scary
as hell it is
because you don't know who you are
anymore
yeah and
you're trying to forgive something that
is a vapor because I don't think you've
sat and grieved
the loss of your marriage the loss of
the vision of what that was
because you married that guy you all had
plans right
yep we had a lot of them yeah
and when you had a child with special
needs you love that kid and you grieved
that too because that wasn't what you
drew up for nine months right
not at all and then you had this life
that you had not planned and here it is
and
he went one degree left and you went one
degree right and you woke up a few years
later and you had no idea where that
dude was because y'all were both inside
the planet
yeah right
so it's more like I had woke up one day
and realized I had plans and he was just
along for the ride yeah you know and
I but it's both in though because if I
sat down with him I could almost
guarantee you he would say dude she
didn't listen to a word I said
I just sat here and she ran through
everything because she was this she was
that had to be this way so I just
unplugged that'd be I almost be willing
to bet that's what he would say
yeah is that true
maybe
I don't know so
here's where we're gonna start the way
one you have to take ownership of what
you did the role you played
okay I gotta I have to own this I've got
to take blame out blame is contextual
and it's good but it doesn't solve any
problems doesn't help
yeah I gotta own what I did
I've got to own that I was capable of
doing something that I despised in other
people yet here I am
so the word is ownership ownership
ownership this happened period
the other thing is when you started
telling me
what happened
I wrote down you are still in disbelief
I can hear it in your voice
you still can't believe you did that yep
you cannot go back and edit sentences
that have already been written
unfortunately right yeah it is it is and
it's heartbreaking and sad and it is but
it's also the path forward to Healing
I can be a monster
and now I'm dedicated to not being that
person anymore
I wish it was more complicated than that
but it's not after you grieve this and
you take full ownership of your role in
this
the context again it's important but
it's it's over now now I've got to own
here's what I did and until you can say
those words out loud without I got a
close buddy who's very open I met my
spouse
um
uh through uh an affair is able to say
it with a period at the end of the
sentence and have a lot of guilt and
shame over it and here's who I have
chosen to become on the back end
beautiful that's what healing looks like
yeah yeah right so
it's ownership it is grieving and then
it is asking yourself that one
terrifying frightening awful scary
question
what am I going to do now
who am I gonna be now
so I'll ask you who are you gonna be
gosh possibilities are endless aren't
they they are
but you haven't even thought that you're
still beating yourself up
can I say something weird and I'm going
to get some mean comments on the
internet about me I don't think you're a
bad person
I don't
I think you I think you were tired
and I think you are absolutely Stone
lonely
and I think you and your husband ran to
situation where neither of you all had
the tools and I'll say neither of you
all had the character to go try to get
those tools but here we are
I don't think you're a bad person I
think you screwed up
yeah you know you know
start crashing on you know in the
comments section dude you can't read
that stuff if I can defend you for a
second
um I was I was those people I I never
actually would verbally say out loud
you know you're a bad person but you
know it's
I would have to say that anything what
I've learned through this is to just
have sympathy
you know well so my my I may have talked
about this one of the things that one of
the most important lessons my dad taught
me
um he was a homicide detective when I
was a kid in Houston so he saw this some
bad stuff
and he said the hardest part of his job
was not the blood and the guts he said
the hardest part of his job
sitting at a card table with somebody
who was an alleged murderer
and listening to their story
and sitting back in his little metal
folding chair realizing oh my gosh but
for two or three things that happen in a
day I'm that guy
I would have done that exact thing given
this situation on top of this one on top
of this one and then I went home and my
wife was with the mailman somebody's
gonna die right it all just happens
right in a row and all of a sudden as a
society we've gone murderer
and my dad said sitting across from a
Broken Man and feeling that Humanity
all of a sudden the labels don't make a
lot of sense because I'm looking at a
hurt guy right here who did Evil and
atrocity and has to be held accountable
for it make no mistake
yeah
um but
so I'm not I'm not gonna throw a rock at
you Sherry I'm snot
I'm not
um you know right it's there's no sense
in being like well you know what you do
yes you know more than anybody you know
the question is who am I going to be now
and not like what not what am I not
going to do I'm never gonna cheat again
I'm that's like me saying I'm never
gonna eat jelly beans again that's
stupid all right that's gonna happen
um it is creating a new identity that
begins with here's who I am
I'm a person who is impeccably
trustworthy
all the time forever
and that means you're going to fudge on
something you're gonna you're gonna tell
your your boss gonna be like hey you got
that reported and be like oh yeah I
emailed it to you let me go check and
see you know you didn't email it
you're going to circle back and say hey
I didn't email this here it is I'm sorry
you're gonna practice being a person of
impeccable integrity
and a part of that is I do not chat with
guys at work because I know what that's
like some people can do that some people
can have drinks on the weekend some
can't
and you Sherry cannot and that means for
the first time in your life you're gonna
have to figure out why you don't like
Sherry
and why flirting and male attention
is so important it's like oxygen to you
and that comes back from a long long
time ago is that fair yeah
so you're talking about a whole new way
of being
I mean that's easy enough right oh
simple yeah yeah I wanted to name my
book um how to change everything and my
wife was like that's too much that's too
much I'm not doing that I'm not doing
that
but here's the thing here so people ask
me like what do you mean when you say
practice here's what I mean
when a chat window pops up and you're in
Zoom or you're at a conference and some
guy sits by you and makes a joke and you
laugh and you scoot a little bit closer
or you intentionally bump your foot
against his
or you text back a funny joke
and then he texts back and you text back
it it's catching yourself right there
yeah
sketching stuff right there
and exhaling and saying this goes off
it's that simple and then you got to
live in that discomfort of I'm not
getting propped up by somebody else
right now that means I gotta go home and
deal with what's at home
and I gotta go home and deal with what's
in the mirror and that's so hard
you know what I mean yeah
are you willing to do that
absolutely
and uh this is going to be hard it may
not be with the guy you're with that may
not be the long-term play here
or y'all both might say
both of us didn't make good choices both
of us did things that were regrettable
and not good both of us hurt other
people we start cleaning here together
and I've seen that work great but it
takes both people being committed
yeah is he that guy
he is definitely that guy for real
I I don't
I don't know how
you know when you you do a lot of bad
things in your life and you you ask
yourself
well I mean you you feel like you don't
deserve anything good because you're not
a good person you know but for some
reason
I I can't explain it but he saved me
from
from a lot of stuff
and um he's willing you know and I think
that's one of the understandings that we
have
is that we know what each other are
capable of you know yeah but that's how
the US and Russia have gotten along for
a long time and it doesn't work in the
long term
we uh were able to have very Frank and
open conversations which is
you know it's it's difficult at times do
y'all have any secret do you have
secrets you keep from him no
no okay no we didn't we we do not keep
Seekers from each other are you still in
communication with your ex
yes we're we're on we're in pretty
friendly terms
have you ever sat down with him and said
I'm sorry
absolutely how'd that go I've
um he was very receptive okay he was he
was kind about it that hurts even worse
doesn't it yeah
push that yourself it'd be fun if you
flip the table over it's like oh yeah
and you can feel Justified like yeah
exactly it sucks from the people we hurt
or have super High character and
integrity doesn't it
and and they're kind yes
um
here's your homework assignment are you
ready
okay I want you to write a letter that
begins dear Sherry
can you do that okay
and it will be the things that you're
disappointed Sherry did
it's going to be about the things that
you absolutely s just don't love About
Cherry
and then it's going to be in part three
of this letter
here's who Sherry's gonna be
a woman of impeccable Integrity I'm
going to be the best romantic partner
ever
my husband or my boyfriend or whatever
you want to call him he may have quote
unquote saved me but he's not my savior
yeah he pulled me out of the water but
it's my job to walk now
and so I am a person who's committed to
getting well I'm a person who's
committed to growth
I'm committed to being a light in my
community and that means I've got to
understand that I'm worth being loved
even though I did dumb stuff I'm worth
being loved
yeah will you tell Sherry that because
she's been needing to hear that probably
since she was a little girl
you promise because I like Sherry
yeah
I can do that okay I promise and I will
say this again to people watching and
listening
we're not throwing rocks on this one
because for those of you listening to
statistically speaking this is a lot
more of you than y'all want to admit
and y'all may not have made the final
plans like Sherry did
but you thought about it you gotten
close
or your roommates with the person you're
married to and it's been a long time
finding people to throw rocks at almost
never solves anybody's problems
look in the mirror and saying I'm gonna
make my home my marriage my parenting my
community a little bit better
that's where we start
Sherry I'm grateful for your bravery for
your honesty and for just calling and
saying I'm going to lay it all out there
I'm grateful for you
ownership forgiveness grief
and then that scary question who am I
going to be now
we'll be riding with you Sherry thank
you so much